no i don't believe in that statement i  don't believe men get women pregnant  know what i mean when i get pregnant no  it's 100 percent the fault of the woman  if you get pregnant if you get pregnant  that's on you as a woman 100 it's not a  man so i'll tell you how i'll explain  how i'll explain how every woman is head  of security for their own vagina  every woman is head of security right  and the only the only if it's not a  great situation  you let somebody in  just like there's a door here  if it's not a burglar situation  someone let someone into this place and  hang on and hang on and the  responsibility for letting if you didn't  vet the person properly or if they  didn't show their id and you believed it  you didn't look at the id that's on you  because once they run up in your house  and burgle your house that's going to be  on you  you have to be hang on but no but you  have to be head of security for your own  vagina